from leading roles major brand
sponsorships millions of dollars and
global recognition the actors of squid
game have encountered opportunities they
never could have imagined this might be
a little bit bigger than my usual
project she may have been a successful
model before but now hoyon is a global
star she can earn around 43 000 u.s per
sponsored instagram post and she's
working in partnership with huge brands
like adidas and louis vuitton definitely
worth the investment for these companies
since she's the most popular south
korean actress on instagram
um
the wealth and popularity have had a
huge effect on the sabjok actress she
felt pretty changed as a person as well
hoiyon grew very close to her character
and had a hard time letting her go
sometimes feeling like sabjuk's voice
comes through in her always teaching and
changing her for the better
chung-jae didn't have instagram before
squid game so he opened up an account
and made his first post just a couple
weeks after the show premiered and
quickly gained over 4 million followers
the actor has been lurking on social
media now that memes photos and fan
theories for squid game have been taking
over and he's even found a light in the
parody videos the actor feels in terms
of his career the show's success hasn't
done a lot for him but the day-to-day
has been very different because suddenly
he's being recognized whenever he's out
the gion actor is already busy at work
on another project and while he hasn't
heard from any north american companies
about doing a project with them he's
very open to the idea and would jump at
the chance to travel and film overseas
the police officer on a mission has had
quite the rise in popularity and his
cover of men's health korea definitely
helped it's no surprise his follower
count jumped from around 300 000 to
about 9 million his life didn't just
change financially and professionally
though he actually overcame a phobia of
water after the show because of all the
lessons and work he had to do for
underwater filming in the series it was
a big step but one that's been very
worth it for the actor
is already busy and booked on other
projects including the film ghost and
two netflix shows suriname and a korean
adaptation of another popular series
money heist with a net worth of around
three to four million this actor is
definitely earning his success
the biggest change since the show though
would be his new role as a father to a
baby nicknamed baby squid who happened
to be born the day the show premiered
talk about a life turning upside down
the creator and director of squid game
has been blown away by just how
successful the program has been and
shocked by the fact that he could find
this kind of success it's of course been
a pretty emotional time considering how
quickly squid game rose to success
especially since he wrote the series
over a decade ago there has been a ton
of demand for a second season but huang
had never actually planned on another
one however there were some cliffhangers
at the end of the first season and fans
have offered all sorts of amazing ideas
and theories that have really inspired
the director's thinking while the
pressure is definitely high he's opened
and excited to potentially bring squid
game back for another season
i'll steal the ideas from the fans
player 1 the mastermind behind squid
game was in control on the show but in
real life he's been extremely
overwhelmed with all the buzz around
himself and the series while he's been
acting for many years he's never gotten
so many inquiries and offers so his
daughter had to start helping him run
his career since he never had a manager
who'd normally take care of these
matters the actor has already been
offered starring roles in tv commercials
and has had to turn some down we can
only imagine how many people would
recognize him out in public if he did
commercials as well the actor only
recently came to terms with just how
tough it can be to be famous
the actor originally from india has
become extremely popular and is getting
way more recognition than he ever
thought he would people are taking
selfies they want to take autographs and
with the exposure has come the hope that
maybe he could perform in india and in
his own language the journey he had to
get to this point in his career is
exceptional
he moved to korea because he had a
scholarship to study and now he's worth
around half a million dollars we have a
feeling his dream to perform in front of
his hometown audience is pretty probable
at this point these days there's
so many calls
while the actor is now a self-proclaimed
millionaire after reaching 1 million
followers on instagram
his health did suffer in the process of
making the show because of how quickly
he bulked up and gained weight resulting
in him often being sick and really
struggling during the strenuous days on
set he is still dealing with the
ramifications of the intense body
transformation leaving him wary to take
on any jobs that require him to gain
that much weight so quickly it hasn't
all been bad though the actor can make
around 1 000 per sponsored instagram
post
the front man actor in the series is
actually one of the few south korean
actors who's established a reputation in
hollywood in the gi joe films and
terminator genesis while in the states
he dealt with some racism on sets but
with the success of squid game he hasn't
given up on hollywood yet and he's still
wanting to make films in the u.s his
growing popularity and central role as
the mysterious front man has given way
to rumors that a second season could
focus on his story our fingers are
crossed dream come true
so
that's great thing the vips and squid
game were talked about but not
necessarily for the right reasons since
there has been a lot of criticism about
their performances in the hit show the
actor who played vip number four isn't
too bothered by the negative reactions
since he's still been receiving a ton of
recognition the actor also gets fan mail
autograph requests and one admirer even
went so far as to tattoo both his real
name and the character's name on her arm
definitely not much to complain about in
his own words i'm in the most popular
film
in the history of television as for vip
number two all the flak wasn't so great
and he was pretty upset by the comments
mostly i just try to take what i can
from the negativity or the you know the
criticisms vip number one wasn't a fan
of being distant reviews but he's also
aware of the stereotypes that exist in
the entertainment industry for
westerners in south korea vip1 has
mainly been advocating for actors like
himself making sure to explain that they
do still have to go through a rigorous
audition process to book a role instead
of just being picked up off the streets
the actor who played the slick recruiter
in the series was actually one of the
biggest names in the show he rose to
international fame when he did the film
trained to busan his performance in the
netflix series earned him even more fans
and many of the squid game followers are
hoping that he'll have a leading role if
there's a second season perhaps the
strangest change he's encountered since
the show took off has been the fact that
now loads of people want to be slapped
by him and aren't shy in letting the
actor know
performing since she was a teenager yumi
is a seasoned actor now but nothing
prepared her for the rapid rise to fame
while she had an impressive 40 000
followers on instagram before the show
came out she very quickly gained about 6
million more fans professionally the
ball is kept rolling and she's already
filming other projects including a
netflix film called all of us are dead
as for her personal life squid game
brought the actress one of her closest
friends she and hoiyon talk to each
other every day having developed an
incredible real-life friendship
it's great to see the actors of squid
game becoming so successful
just goes to show anything can happen in
show business we're hoping their
popularity continues and we'll get to
see them all on screen more
which brand do you think is going to get
player 1 to be a brand ambassador